I'm a dietitian and I will never cook  with this oil flax okay I know you're  probably expecting me to say canola but  contrary to what all the other  nutritionists on this app will tell you  canola actually has a very Miracle  omega-3 to omega-6 ratio and it's got a  high smoke point so it's great for  cooking flax oil on the other hand is  often touted in Wellness circles as  being super healthy and it is it's  loaded with plant-based ala Omega-3s  it's got a crazy low smoke point so it's  really not appropriate for anything  other than dressings dips finishing on  meats or vegetables and adding to  smoothies my cooking oil of choice is  avocado it's got a higher smoke point  than olive oil but it's still got the  same heart healthy monounsaturated fats  plus it's super versatile and delicious  for cooking or using Raw